this is the most troubling story I've
seen all week and it has nothing to do
with the Border or the 2024 race or any
of that
has to do within
an Instagram lady it has to do with a
social media influencer she's 23 years
old she's got 1.8 million followers on
Snapchat alone to say nothing of the
other social media platforms her name is
Karen Marjorie and she has created a
chat bot
her chat bot is called chat or Karen A.I
and users of this chat bot pay one
dollar per minute to speak to a robot
that pretends to be her
and in the first week of its beta test
this woman made seventy thousand dollars
I'm looking over at my producer Ben
Davies over we're in the wrong line of
work we oh man I should have just been a
young hot chick and then can you imagine
how much especially one with nerd techie
friends because then you don't actually
have to do anything
at all you can Outsource even
social media
thirst traps you can Outsource even that
to an algorithm
now what does this gal say she says
Karen A.I will never replace me Karen AI
is simply just an extension of me an
extension of my Consciousness because
her schtick is that she amasses all
these followers with these young lonely
men who
presumably don't have girlfriends or
don't care about their girlfriends very
much and so they're chatting with this
Phantom of a human being over
Snapchat over Instagram DMs
and this is how she makes her money and
becomes popular but there were too many
guys so she just outsourced it to a
robot
she says Karen AI is going to come fill
that Gap she says that Karen AI might
cure loneliness quote whether you need
somebody to be comforting or loving or
you just want to rant about something
that happened at school or at work Karen
AI will always be there for you this is
the saddest thing I've read in a very
long time
but it's working she thinks it this that
this
operation could make her millions of
dollars of not only a month maybe a week
who knows 70 grand in the beta test
that's unbelievable
and it and it might
why does this work though it doesn't
just work because of the new technology
it works because of the way Society
already operates
this is what's so damning about the
whole thing this is what's so depressing
the reason that this chat bot thing
works is because the chat bot isn't all
that different from regular modern
social interaction
so much regular modern social
interaction is shallow
transactional
and virtual
so shallow in that
we don't
we don't treat one another as Eternal
beings
with whom we're endeavoring to create a
life and to learn something about
reality and to build something up
together and to have children no one's
having children no one's getting married
it's transactional the modern dating
culture is is a hookup culture
it's it's like out of an irand novel you
just you don't you don't lay down with
somebody because you love this person
and this person's your spouse and you're
open to life and you're gonna have a big
family and a good life no you just do it
because it's okay I want to feel good
tonight and you're reasonably pleasing
to me and hopefully the same is true in
the other direction so we'll do that but
no strings attached no nothing we
certainly won't have kids we won't get
married and a lot of it's just virtual
my friends who are on the dating apps I
missed the dating apps because sweet
little Elise and I got back together
just when that was starting to come out
so I've never been on them but my
friends are on them
all they ever really do is just send
messages occasionally they'll go on
dates I guess but
those of you who are on dating apps know
this better than I do second hand
so much of the time you spend with
dating apps is just on the app just
messaging even when you're off the app
what are you doing you're just texting
people it's all just virtual so what's
the difference
when I'm in the room with a real human
being
I can I can still to today tell the
difference between a human being and a
robot but if you're just texting with
somebody if all you want to do is just
get your jollies off or rant or complain
or whatever
what is the difference between Karen A.I
and Karen Marjorie a 23 year old
Snapchat girl
practically speaking there isn't one
right now go to balanceofnature.com use
promo code Knowles living a healthy
lifestyle is not always easy especially
when you're always on the go you need
simple manageable routines to make sure
you're getting the proper nutrition
every day which is why I'm a huge fan of
balance of nature balance of nature
fruits and veggies are a great way to
ensure you're getting essential
nutritional ingredients daily their
capsules are packed with 100 whole food
that you can take at any time balance of
nature uses a cold vacuum process that
preserves the natural phytonutrients in
whole fruits and vegetables and
encapsulates them for easy consumption
balance of nature sent a bunch of their
products down to the studio for our team
to try and we all love them make fruits
and vegetables a part of your daily diet
your body will thank you if you want to
be a hulking Adonis like a little old me
over here go check it out go to
balanceofnature.com use promo code
Knowles Canada W Las for 35 off your
first order is a preferred customer that
is balance of nature.com promo code
Knolls for 35 off your first order make
sure you're getting those vitamins and
nutrients you need they taste great too
and unlike at the daily wire hopefully
around your home all those jackals won't
come and take them before you have the
chance to get your fill promo code knows
35 off your first order it's a sad fact
but conservatives simply cannot trust
the federal agencies between what we
learned from the Durham report
and what we've just seen over the past
several years but from the Catholic
memoranda going around the FBI saying
we're going to infiltrate Catholic
churches we're gonna we're going to try
to cultivate priests as assets to spy on
their parishes because if you're a
traditional catholic and you go to the
Latin Mass can you imagine heaven for
fend why you're probably a threat you
might be a terrorist
we've got terrorists pouring across our
Southern border that that's fine maybe
we'll pick up one or two of them but the
ones we really got to focus on those
Catholics those Christians those parents
who don't want their kids to be
indoctrinated into critical race Theory
and gender theory in kindergarten
they're the real terror threat
how can we trust our own agencies we
know that they lie to destroy us
and it's not even as though they cooked
up some plot to entrap or to just
baselessly smear some random Fringe
figure they did it to the Republican
nominee for president who later became
the Republican president
they'll do it to all of us speaking of
lawlessness in government
a Democrat Senator is now declaring a
popular Revolt if the Supreme Court
affirms the Second Amendment
if the Supreme Court eventually says
that states or the Congress can't pass
Universal background checks or can't
take these assault weapons off the
streets I think there's going to be a
popular Revolt over that policy a court
that's already pretty illegitimate is
going to be in full crisis mode
this is not just some talking head
pundit mouthing off on NBC News this is
a sitting U.S senator this is a Democrat
political leader
saying you know I'll tell you the
Court's not legitimate one of the three
branches of government it's not
legitimate and so if they uphold the
American
tradition of self-protection and the
Second Amendment and the Constitution
I just think there's going to be a
popular revolt well that's a nice
Society you got there it's a nice
Courthouse you got there it's a nice
Civil Society sure would be a shame if
there were a popular Revolt wouldn't it
Supreme Court I think you know what to
do talking like a monster and this is
what they always do this is what they
did during BLM hmm you're going to
oppose some of the radical BLM demands
you're not going to give zillions of
dollars to far left-wing groups to fund
left-wing politicians uh you're not
going to acquiesce to the leftist
policies oh it's a nice business you got
sure would be a shame if something
happened to it
that's what they always tell us
what Democrat Chris Murphy is calling
for here
is no less than an insurrection
and he's framing his advocacy of such a
thing as mere prediction but it's Not
Mere prediction because he's saying that
the Court's illegitimate the court is
lost legitimacy and I I tell you if I
were a Gambling Man I would imagine
there might be a popular revolt
the simple sentences that Chris Murphy
uttered on Meet the Press
are a far more serious type of
insurrection than anything that happened
around January sixth the worst day in
the history of politics it's not even
close
and this is what they do this is what
they regularly do and this is why
very few things get me angry I'm pretty
even tempered very cool but when the
squishes take the bait and for every
stupid lie that they cook up about
Donald Trump they've been cooking up
one lie more Preposterous than the next
since the 2016 campaign all the way up
to the level of the CIA director and the
FBI director and the president of the
United States
when the squishes buy into this stuff
when they buy into the language around
the insurrection
give me a break the libs regularly call
for insurrections they just did so on
national TV I guess that's the
difference when the conservatives do an
Insurrection it's an eccentric horn hat
guy dancing around the capital rotunda
with police protection getting a private
tour of the capital it's a granny taking
a picture in the capital rotunda and
when the Democrats call for an
Insurrection they call for a popular
Revolt they support violence in the
streets and they do so on National
Television that's the difference
I know what you're thinking that was a
great clip if you want more if you want
the longer form interviews if you want
the yes or no game if you want face off
if you want the breakouts if you want
the full show you got it subscribe ring
that Bell Michael Knowles YouTube
channel see you next time